l'écologie grande absente du débat
présidentiel dans les Yvelines SEP
candidats d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
feront entendre leur voix en faveur de
l'environnement tous impliqués dans des
associations locales ou en politique
comme Olivier parjat élu municipal
aguill encour et à l'agglomération de 50
ans en Yveline il est candidat pour la
première circonscription et faire que
chacun retrouve une place digne donc
avec le partage du temps de travail par
exemple avec le fait d'avoir un logement
descend le fait que la pollution en
Île-de-France c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il faut absolument travailler
nous sommes dans des zones proches des
zones agricoles là aussi il y a quelque
chose à faire préserver la ruralité un
des axes de campagne de Patricia Charton
elle est candidate dans la 12e
circonscription des Yveline face à David
Douillet une dururbadisation à à grand à
grand train qui vient manger les terres
agricoles on le voit sur plaisir on le
voit on le voit aussi sur poissie on
sait que le PSG a acheté les terres du
Pons par exemple la ruralité quelque
chose de très important pour pour les
gens qui sont venus habiter là autre
enjeu pour le parti la nomination de
Nicolas HULLOT au ministère de la
transition écologique la présence
d'Europe Écologie Les vert à l'Assemblée
permettrait d'appuyer ses projet une
vision écologiste à l'Assemblée c'est
effectivement mettre l'accent sur un
certain nombre de problématiques
environnementales mais c'est
également mettre l'accent sur une
certaine vision de l'économie une vision
de l'économie qui à mon sens est celle
du futur à savoir économie qualitative
mais j'ai l'impression que mis à part
les écologistes personne ne comprend
cette nouvelle façon dont la société va
s'orienter dans certaines
circonscriptions Europe Écologie Les
vert a fait des alliances avec les
partis communistes et socialistes c'est
le cas dans les deux et troisème
circonscription avec tangy Ruellan et
Nicolau pour la 10e circonscription
David Jutier représentera l'écologie
dans le fief de Jean-Frédéric Poisson
dans la 11e aucun candidat n'a été
investi